the taliban has a annual budget or
annual revenue of 1.6 billion dollars in
the fiscal year that ended in march
2020.
literally one of the most violent
terrorist organizations in the world 1.6
billion dollars now where does that
money come from we've got an entire
breakdown of their financials we've got
a chart that shows line by line where
the cash comes from and so to start you
can see that they take in about 400
million dollars or so from drugs
they've got 400 million dollars from
mining 160 million dollars from
extortion and taxes 240 million dollars
of foreign donations exports make up
another 240 real estate's 80 million and
then on top of that
there's another up to 500 million
dollars that comes from specific country
contributions so let's get into the
drugs first we've got two photos that i
want to show you which shows the nuance
and the complexity of what's going on in
afghanistan the first photo
is an individual with
a rocket launcher sitting in the fields
the next photo
is other
soldiers standing with rifles in a field
same fields
two different sides
now the drugs bring in 416 million
dollars afghanistan over the last five
years has accounted for approximately 84
of global opium production
that is a
monstrous number
afghanistan is responsible for 84 of
global opium production over the last
five years the taliban
which
has opium in areas under their control
imposes a 10 tax on every single link in
the drug production chain
that includes the farmers
that includes a 10 tax on the labs that
turn the plant into a drug and that
includes the logistics of getting the
drugs out of the country
multiple points in that supply chain the
taliban takes a 10 tax and it leads to
over 400 million dollars of annual
revenue afghanistan brought 84 of global
opium production over the last five
years absolutely nuts at the same time
that the us is occupying their country
another 400 to 464 million dollars
there's two different estimates we found
so somewhere between 400 to 450 million
comes from mining
now there's iron ore marble copper gold
zinc and other materials and minerals
that are in the country of afghanistan
it is even estimated that afghanistan
may have one of the greatest lithium
deposits in the entire world
obviously there are some legitimate
businesses that are mining these
minerals and they are going and bringing
them to the global stage and driving
revenue but also the taliban
both with illegal mining but also
taxation on top of those legitimate
businesses and so if there's money to be
made the taliban is going to put their
hand into it they make 400 or 464
million dollars from the mining of iron
ore marble copper gold zinc and other
minerals or materials there are small
scale mineral extraction operations and
then also big afghan mining companies
and they basically pay the taliban to
allow them to run their businesses
which leads us to
what is usually classified as taxes and
everyone always puts in parentheses
potentially extortion
the
taliban made 160 million dollars last
year from extortion and taxes the tax
industries include mining operations
media telecommunications and development
projects funded by international aid
they do everything from a 10 tax on
farmers harvest to a two and a half
percent wealth tax that's right the
taliban issues a two and a half percent
wealth tax on the people in the areas
under their control drivers are charged
for using highways in taliban controlled
regions
shopkeepers pay to keep their shops open
the taliban when they take over an area
or they control an area they get paid
it's no different than the mafia or
anybody else they basically say we will
protect you we will allow you to run
your business we won't mess with you but
just pay us your tax anywhere from two
and a half percent wealth tax up to as
much as 10
for these various things then you start
getting into really really weird parts
of their financials things like foreign
donations now
foreign donations seems like a
nondescript
title for this section
it's categorized as private donors and
international institutions across the
globe in persian gulf countries private
citizens from saudi arabia pakistan iran
and other persian gulf nations
i don't really know exactly where the
240 million dollars come from but 240
million dollars makes its way from
outside of afghanistan into the
taliban's pockets through what they call
donations at one point we read an
article and they categorized it as
charitable donations and i said we will
not categorize that as charitable
donations it is a foreign donation
exports makes up another 240 million
dollars there are various everyday
consumer goods including
poppy and opium
and looted minerals which we already
discussed but they also have a lot of
effort energy and all sorts of products
in the automobile and auto parts
industry afghanistan actually is one of
the greatest exporters of auto parts in
the world and so of course there's money
being made there's exports going out of
taliban controlled areas they're taking
their taxes they're getting paid 240
million dollars of those exports and
then in one of the craziest line items
the taliban made 80 million dollars
on real estate
they own real estate in afghanistan
pakistan and potentially other countries
we don't know everything obviously but
it's estimated 80 million dollars from
real estate i don't know if that means
that the taliban is a landlord and
literally you show up and they say give
me my rent and that's part of this
revenue i don't know how that works in
other countries where the taliban may
not have a stronghold but there's
estimated 80 million dollars in real
estate revenue that comes from the
taliban
it comes to the taliban and then lastly
there are what we categorized as foreign
countries and so it's estimated that up
to 500 million dollars from russia iran
pakistan and saudi arabia
in 2008 that number was 106 million from
foreign sources today the governments of
russia iran pakistan and saudi arabia
are believed to bankroll the taliban and
experts say it could be the to the tune
of up to 500 million dollars a year
absolutely bonkers when you start to
think about this now we have an
infographic i want to show you how
quickly the taliban who had almost no
control of the country while the u.s
occupation was playing out
two in the last couple of weeks
now this taxation
this control of the country how quickly
it changed hands and remember
the taliban controls more of afghanistan
today than they did before these are not
good people
i personally don't agree with their view
of the world i don't think my brothers
do as well they can speak for themselves
we're not here to claim that we should
log these people we're not claiming that
we should uh put these people up on a
pedestal it's actually the exact
opposite but what we do believe is that
the way that you understand these
organizations the way that you could
potentially disrupt these organizations
is understanding how to follow the money
where is 1.6 billion dollars coming from
that is funding the taliban in
afghanistan so here's the infographic
that we have which shows you
exactly how this starts this is what it
was july 12th july 19th july 23rd july
29th
august 5th august 6th august 10th get
ready august 11th august 12th august
13th here we go august 15th 16th
absolute nuts in about a month now
here's the crazy part that little yellow
spot there that is the contested area
no longer is outside of taliban control
either from what we understand and so
the taliban in about a month
went from controlling very little of the
country to controlling everything and so
if you see that 1.6 billion dollar
number from a revenue standpoint in the
fiscal year that ended march 2020 my
guess is that the fiscal year that we
are in right now is going to be much
much higher the taliban is absolutely
emboldened when it comes to
taxation extortion and their various
business lines 85 of all opium
production in the world comes from
afghanistan on top of that they may be
sitting on the largest lithium mine in
the world
how we figure this stuff out
i don't know i'm not here to claim
efficacy or accuracy to every single
thing that we read in the news but what
i do know is it's way more money than
most people would have expected and the
growth of this has been insane i think
that there's been what almost 10x growth
in the taliban revenue over the last
five years or so yes i was just looking
it up the taliban revenue grew from 400
million dollars in 2011 to 1.6 billion
today so that's 300 percent up in in 10
300. yeah
wow yeah it's crazy all while right the
us government was spending trillions of
dollars uh within the country trying to
kill them trying to kill them obviously
but to build up a sustainable government
to increase financial literacy and
literacy in general in the country and
uh to suppress violence right and then
you look at the map in three days two
three days that's all it took for the
majority of the country to fall back
under taliban control the part to me
that uh i want to be extra extra careful
that we explicitly say is these are not
good people right in terms of the what
they're doing uh i do want to call out
that there is a cnn reporter which
people have their problems with cnn etc
but this woman clarissa ward i think is
her name uh she has been on the streets
literally interviewing the taliban
standing there on a street i saw a video
today there's not another woman out in
the street and she's sitting there she's
and she's literally interviewing people
she's bringing the story etc and it's
just pretty incredible to see one how
courageous that woman is and her ability
to continue to report under these
conditions but two is when we start to
really understand uh the business that's
at play here right we talked yesterday
about the defense industry and see if
you guys notice what we did we got big
brains over here we went first on the
u.s side what is the financials who's
making money here how does the u.s
government spend well we don't even know
is it billions hundreds of billions
trillions of dollars nobody knows on top
of that we looked at the defense
contractors and how much money they've
made over the last 20 years since we
fought these what seemed like forever
wars and now we're looking at the
taliban so it seems like the united
states the defense contractors and the
taliban everyone keeps making more and
more money but the people who lose in
these situations are the everyday
citizens who live in this country the
people of afghanistan are almost no
better off today than they were
10 years ago i think the only thing that
we found that is undisputed
increase in the quality of life is the
literacy rate in afghanistan right yeah
i don't want to quote the numbers wrong
but essentially what i s what i had seen
yesterday was some somewhere around five
or three percent or less than ten
percent uh for sure was the literacy
rate within the country before the us
got there and now it's up to closer to
45 or 50 so that's increased
dramatically uh but you have to wonder
like what's going to happen back under
taliban control right women and and uh
women were being kicked out of school i
saw uh on social media the other day and
like these are all the things that they
don't want to happen under their control
so uh it's tough because you have to
imagine kind of worst case scenario
what's gonna happen for the next five or
ten years if this is what life's gonna
be like uh but that was yes one of the
great things that uh the us obviously
did which was bring more literacy to the
country and get people educated and all
these different things hey guys thanks
so much for watching that clip of the
best business show make sure you like
and subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it
you